votre pire émission de télévision
[Musique]
d'amour la plus naze
l'avant-dernière
et j'en parle pas
non non
si tu veux
le plus mauvais souvenirs d'école que
vous ayez
l'arrivée à Cluny en Bourgogne c'était
pas facile il fallait que je m'adapte à
cette nouvelle culture
la personne qui nous a fait le plus de
mal
les gens qui sont pour vous je dirais
pas les couilles
Laurent il arrête pas de râler qu'il se
fait chier
non en fait le pire endroit où j'ai vécu
c'est peut-être au Burundi pendant la
période du massacre parce que on dort
pas tous les jours et on mange pas aussi
bien qu'on le croit voilà
votre pire émission de télévision
et d'ailleurs merci
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu